in brussels they're dreaming of a busy
christmas
shops reopened in belgium on tuesday
despite a recent rise in covet 19
cases but bars and restaurants have to
stay closed
shopkeepers here in belgium are hoping
to make the most of the reopening
but with daily covered 19 infections
rising and the reproduction rate at
almost
one the government's not ruling out
bringing in new restrictions
at the end of this week over the border
in the netherlands they've gone into a
five-week lockdown
closing all non-essential shops as well
as schools
prime minister mark rutter insists that
rising infection rates make it essential
to
in his words bite through this very sour
apple before things get better
it's totally understandable the numbers
are skyrocketing
if this wasn't done the consequences
cannot be neglected
a lockdown is not really the solution
but stricter enforcement like compulsory
face masks using the coronavirus app and
at shopping malls your temperature
should be checked
but there's new hope the prospect of
mass vaccinations across
europe after pressure from the german
government the european union's
regulatory body
is set to approve the pfizer biontech
vaccine next monday
ursula von der lion president of the
european commission tweeted
i welcome the ema bringing forward its
meeting to discuss the pfizer biontech
vaccine before christmas
likely that the first europeans will be
vaccinated before the end of 2020
germany hopes to vaccinate up to 4
million citizens by the end of the year
but with hundreds still dying from the
coronavirus every day
it's bringing in a national lockdown on
wednesday
in france they've lifted a lockdown but
they're bringing in a nighttime curfew
and bars and restaurants remain closed
tuesday saw members of the cultural
industries protest
angry that places like museums and
theaters are not allowed to open
the huge numbers of cinemas in theaters
that will close is catastrophic paris
will no longer be the cultural city it
was before the lockdown
you can't say one sector is essential
and another is not
there's no evidence of clusters in
theaters and cinemas
now the government's advising people to
quarantine before meeting up at
christmas
scientific council is saying and i view
that as reasonable
if you can self-confine for eight days
before christmas
if you can it's not possible for
everyone
across europe the message from
governments is the same please be
careful over christmas
so the new year can be a better one
nadeem baba al-jazeera brussels